los talibanes se toman cau la ciudad más
grande de afganistán y con más de 4
millones y medio de habitantes el
ministro interior afgano comunicó que se
hará una transferencia pacífica del
poder
van mal las fuerzas militares están en
kabul para proteger la seguridad las
fuerzas internacionales también están
para apoyarlos ayer el presidente
decidió enviar una delegación a doha
para buscar un acuerdo vamos a mantener
la seguridad hasta que haya un acuerdo
en la mañana del sábado el grupo
insurgente se había tomado
mazar-i-sharif y jalal-abad en la mañana
del domingo
horas más tarde se hicieron con vania mm
aidan bakr los talibanes controlan 28 de
las 34 capitales provinciales además se
hicieron con bagram la principal base
aérea estadounidense según dijo el
portavoz de los talibanes todos los
presos fueron liberados los talibanes
controlan 26 de las 34 capitales de
provincia miles de afganos huyendo de la
guerra se refugiaron en la capital que
ahora será custodiada por las fuerzas
talibanes hagámonos la situación
continúa así en afganistán entonces
queremos que eeuu vuelva y nos dé armas
para de macomb a canal este sábado el
presidente joe biden anunció que cinco
mil soldados serían enviados a kabul dos
mil más de los planeados anteriormente
sin embargo las banderas talibanes ya
ondean en las principales ciudades
afganas avanzada que comenzó con una
velocidad sin precedentes desde que las
tropas estadounidenses dejaron el país
que habían ocupado durante más de dos
décadas